les poubelles de certaines stars sont
vendus aux enchères humeur pas rumeur
rumeur pas rumeurs absolument pas
rumeurs parues moeurs ou vendus aux
enchères
alors bon pour la petite histoire il
fait poteau voilà c'est les photos pour
abriter ce soir c'est une vieille
vieillevigne exposition les années des
années ou prenez des photos de la belle
de stars c'est beau et on a fait une
expo facebook moi c'est parce qu'ils
intéressent le plus mais nous qui
n'intéresse après ce qu'on aura comme
révélation mais par exemple quelques
photos qu'on va vous montrer à votre
avis à la sas et la photo de qui de la
poubelle de qui déjà des agences as des
joueurs quelques bravo bravo à 14,6 lui
c'est gainsbourg je prends c'est moi si
l'alcool il ya des abonnés quoi ai-je
été remis à deux packages a dit toulalan
alors on vous vous doutez bien que c'est
une expo ils ont aussi mis tous bons ils
ont dit qu'ils retiraient ce qu'était
sexuelle et médicamenteux bas à lui donc
il ya plus rien savoir du petit lucas et
que tu manges des sig est aussi c'est
intéressant quand même à affecter votre
avis sénatrice américaine trêve une
mannequin américain très connu bien
moindre à des réajustements en anglais
ouais à kate moss kate moss absolument
effectivement alors le suivant mais je
pense que si oui lesquelles à achat
ça c'est qu'ils très très très très très
connu j'entends encore chanteuse
riediens à céline dion non mais attends
céline dion n'a pas le mot union
c'est bien c'est des américains et elle
boit la réunion ça serait pas la bonne
marque dominique et pas nous signons
fidji d'accord merci uni c'est un super
marché américain ouais absolument donc
se passe effectivement c'est une grande
chanteuse hélas est âgé maintenant de 9
à 13 ans donne catherine du mal à
chanter chez renault
larcher ou comme catherine c'est là
c'est nous regarde danser madonna c'est
la fille de madonna voit là et regardez
les suivantes qui est un petit bonus
célèbre huile de qui alors je vous dis
le bagad ker aussi acheter un
dictionnaire oui acheter ton
dictionnaire ça tu sais qui c'est qui ça
lotus quoi c'est la tienne c'est là
n'ont pas dépassé 7 et nicholas cage ça
va très bien donc voilà au dessus du
chpo ce qui m'intéresse c'est les
poubelles toi tu fais les poubelles non
mais je suis un père nommé des paparazzi
ont fait j'ai fait la même chose pour un
magazine français
quand j'avais fait à los angeles il ya
quelques années
et effectivement c'est m c'était toute
une technique parce que les stars font
très attention quand elles sortent leurs
poubelles
donc nous on doit déjà se renseigner de
l'heure du passage du camion
ouais et c'est souvent quelqu'un qui
apporte la poubelle qui regarde partout
comme ça ouais et donc n'ont en général
la personne repart et nous on a juste le
temps d'aller récupérer la poubelle et
après c'est du pendjab
après j'ai arrivé dans mon jardin jeu
télé poubelle je faisais le tri est pas
sérieux donc tu fais parfois le camion à
benne quasiment uniquement
et puis de temps en temps il en fallait
plusieurs médias prêtent et donc tu es
tu allé tout seul coup belge et toi
repens dans un jardin et a déjà eu des
vrais scoops noms des vrais scoops non
mais je récupère les strings de pink
leurs casseroles de sharon stone les
lunettes chanel de paris s'il tonne
voilà mais quel beau milieu en effet
c'était tombé sur un test de grossesse
de nadjaf en france aussi ou pas n'ont
jamais pourquoi juridiquement ça sera
compliqué en france ou plus aux rigueurs
ce bel alezan belle vie là ça ne tarde
pas
rien à ces suis même pas sûr je sais pas
interdit par la loi mais moi j'avais été
chez sharon stone pour faire un tournage
effet il y avait une voiture spéciale de
ça ça m'a marqué c'est une voiture
française
ouais il m'avait expliqué que c'était
une voiture qui servait pour ses
employés uniquement pour mettre les
poubelles mais non parce que il les
prenait il aller loin peu dans une
voiture banalisée y jeter à la poubelle
dans une poubelle à des normes pour pas
justement que les papas rang desquels
nous on voit des trucs comme ça on
suivait qu'est la vie horrible
non mais ça auquel il a inscrit les
poubelles de presse avaient déjà arrivé
mais enfin nous on a jamais fouillé mais
poubelles et tant mieux ça assez près de
la paparazzi me l'a pas quels mots notre
confrère nord annoncé que la télé
réalité tout de suite au-dessus et
sophie marceau dont on ne tourne jamais
vu derrière toi deuxième était vide ses
parts et c'est très rare
dadge attaqué la presse people j'ai
saïss n'ont vraiment pas gai pas pour un
cliché demain en maillot de bain jeu
j'étais absolument horrible et c'était à
miami donc d'ailleurs je sais même pas
comment ils m'ont trouvé là-bas parce
que c'était aussi mais voilà
[Rires]